there's the rulers the reverb tank the
ebo a normal instrument you're playing
it and you're expecting it to have a
sound that is pleasing but with an
instrument like this the goal is to just
produce sounds that in this case are
disturbing
[Music]
the apprehension engine was an
instrument that creates a variety of
really creepy and someone say horrifying
sounds my name is Mark Corvin I'm a film
music composer and lately I've been
focusing on horror movie scores two of
my biggest hits as far as horror films
are concerned was from the late 90s a
film called cube and most recently the
which I originally commissioned the
apprehension Asian because I was tired
and the same digital samples which which
resulted in a lot of sameness of a lot
of horror musics so I was looking for
something more experimental more
acoustic that would give me a little bit
more of an original sound that's where I
contacted my friend Tony Duggan Smith so
Mart called me asking me to create a
crazy instrument for horror films
because I've never done anything like
that before
it may be empty out my pockets and all
my drawers of any knickknacks and bits
and bobs as I could possibly string
together to make it happen for him and
this is what camera
[Music]
you're doing those things that stir it
primal motions and the feelings and
there actually is a skill set that you
have to acquire in order to to get the
most out of it
it expresses what really can't be
expressed any other way it's not music
in the traditional sense at all but let
me put it this way the apprehension
engine definitely evokes an emotion so I
would call it easy
you